what's going on guys this is Rob and
what I wanted to do in this video is I
wanted to do a review for Avengers 2 age
of Ultron but what I'd like to do is get
a little deep into this movie as opposed
to simply just saying hey the movie was
great you should go see it peace instead
I wanted to answer a few questions and
so what I've done is I've given myself
some talking points about for talking
points in total which I think should
cover the brunt of some of the more
significant things in this movie and so
if you guys don't want to have age of
Ultron spoiled for you then I would
suggest you guys go ahead and turn the
video off now but if you don't care then
I'd say let's continue so I think one of
the questions a lot of people are going
to have is why does this movie exist why
is this movie here in the film of course
as we know Ultron comes into existence
at the hands of Tony Stark and if you've
seen the film there's really no reason
for me to go into an explanation as to
why any of that's happening but if you
haven't seen the film then just bear
with me or I guess if you have seen the
film bear with me for a second for those
who haven't seen the film yet but Ultron
basically comes into existence when Tony
Stark attempts to create an artificial
intelligence that will serve as a guard
of sorts it'll basically be a
self-contained army that will be able to
protect the planet Earth so the Avengers
don't have to do that forever so they
can simply enjoy their lives they can
have families different things like that
but this basically goes awry when Ultron
is created much like a child
Ultron's curious about everything and
after basically examining all of
humanity over the course of a few
seconds the entire history of humanity
what Ultron rationalizes is that the
only way to really protect humanity is
to protect humanity from itself and so
his argument is the classic I guess
paradox of the violence of humanity
versus humanity's desire to continue
existing and so he simply says that he's
just going to eradicate humanity and
it's entirely it's in his entirety it
seems to be the most rational course of
action and so this basically culminates
and the the film as it leads into the
final confrontation with the Avengers
and Ultron now what we learn here is
that in order for Ultron to officially
be defeated every version of Ultron has
to be destroyed otherwise that version
can escape and produce more
and some when the movie comes to an end
Ultron is totally defeated every version
of Ultron is eradicated so as it stands
now Ultron's not there anymore there's
really no reason to have Ultron in any
future movies I could write it in but it
would probably kind of be considered
nonsensical by a lot of moviegoers and
so the question is what's the basis of
this if it appears to be a
self-contained film then why was a film
made in the first place and this I think
is where things get really cool
what Joss Whedon is doing here with the
Avengers series is he's basically
following the standard of classical
movie trilogies and what I mean by that
is in every movie trilogy
we have the first film which sets the
stage we have the second film that gives
us information and we have the third
film which is the endgame everything
comes to an end and the third film in
Avengers Assemble and Avengers 1 we got
the sage set by Joss Whedon telling us
the only time the Avengers are ever
going to come together is when there's
some kind of massive threat some kind of
global threat that could presumably wipe
out all life or destroy the earth
entirely this is the reason why the
Avengers did not assemble during Captain
America the Winter Soldier there was no
reason for them to there was no purpose
in it we had Captain America we had
Falcon and we had Black Widow and they
were able to single-handedly take out
Hydra there was really no reason to have
Thor or The Incredible Hulk or Iron Man
or anybody like that and the second
films again we basically get all the
information that we need to understand
why things are the way they are for
example and the alien trilogy with alien
and then aliens and alien 3 in the
second film and aliens we learn where
the aliens come from we learned there's
a queen that lays the eggs the eggs
hatch they latch onto a person they
plant a an actual like a xenomorph in
the body of that person it busts out and
the cycle continues on and on and on in
the Godfather trilogy we learned in the
second film how it was Don Corleone had
risen through the ranks to become the
Godfather of the Mafia these are the
kind of things that we had learned in in
those trilogies in age of Ultron to I
guess the age of Ultron is no different
the really cool thing here is that we
really have to look at what it is that
Joss Whedon was doing what he basically
does is he takes this movie and he
heis it into the rest of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe he ties it into
agents of shield for example in the
beginning of the film when we see them
arriving and basically trying to defeat
Hydra when they initially encounter a
Quicksilver and Scarlet Witch both
Captain America and Thor as well as
others refer to them as enhanced people
and enhanced people is a phrase that we
had seen in agents of shield is what
shield referred to as individuals who
have powers or in some capacity are
augmented beyond what people are
normally capable of this may seem like a
very minor thing but this is basically
Joss Whedon telling us and it was
actually confirmed in the discussions
among the characters from age of Ultron
that this is not the first time they've
encountered enhanced people that the
enhanced people we've seen and agents of
shield exist alongside individuals in
this film and bad characters that we
haven't seen yet have been encountered
by the by the Avengers proper as they
were continuing to try to track down
Hydra and destroy the various Hydra
bases now that's a relatively minor
thing and the reason why I say that's a
relatively minor thing is because the
big picture here is Avengers 3 the
infinity war Thanos gaining the Infinity
Gauntlet I guess getting the Infinity
stones all that all the Ultron aside all
that stuff out of the way I'm a the
Ultron battles the conflicts you know
sokovia saving the city and all that
kind of stuff the most important part of
this film came in about a three or
four-minute segment out of the entire
thing and it was when the Scarlet Witch
had used her powers on four there were
two two possibilities with the idea of
Thor the first was confirmed and the
second is kind of a theory that's
running out there among those who have
seen age of Ultron so far the the
confirmed thing is of course as we saw
in the film basically all the Infinity
stones being gathered by Thanos and then
Thanos just killing everybody I mean
that was the vision that was basically
given to us that is as far as Thor is
concerned that seems to be the case that
Thanos will gain the infinity gems and
kill everyone
what joss whedon also did in this film
is he confirmed what the Infinity stones
are the big question a lot of people had
is with the tesseract for example if the
tesseract is an infinity stone the wise
is in the shape of the cube if the ether
is an infinity stone then why is it
would state what he basically told us is
that these various forms of the Infinity
stones are designed that way to protect
the Infinity stones the liquid form of
the ether means the stone itself can't
be harmed it can't actually be destroyed
the it gets cube cube casing of the of
the tesseract of the space gym basically
means that that gem is protected by the
cube itself by the power within it with
regards to the staff of Loki as we saw
it was an actual jewel of sorts that
housed the gem proper what joss whedon
told us is that these are all stones
these are actual stones once they take
form and when they do a person can wield
them appropriately and so what this
basically did is it was Joss Whedon
saying this movie is basically a lead-up
to infinity war this is basically just
establishing to us that at this point in
time in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
four of the stones have been revealed
the ether which is the reality stone the
space gem I guess the the tesseract
which is the space stone the staff of
Loki which house the mind stone and then
finally the power stone which we saw in
guardians of the galaxy and so this is
why this film exists the purpose of this
film is to basically lead us up to
infinity war to say here's where we
stand in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
with all of the Infinity stones and it
did it in spectacular fashion
I thought this film was absolutely
mind-blowing now here's the next thing I
really wanted to take some time to talk
about the personality of Ultron the
personality of Ultron for me is such
that this version that we see in the
films is different from the one of the
comics but it's also pretty cool um I
like that Ultron was basically curious
about humanity Ultron was very human in
this film he had a lot of human elements
when he first emerges he's very curious
as to why it is humanity wants to exist
but Humanity is so self-destructive he
basically looks at Humanity as kind of a
very interesting concept but also seems
to have this idea that destroying
humanity seems to be the only real
course of action he's basically doing
what he feels needs to be done and I
think one of the coolest elements one of
the coolest statements made about Ultron
was made by the Scarlet Witch when she
when she said Ultron doesn't know how to
differentiate between order and
he doesn't know how to differentiate
between saving humanity and destroying
humanity and this I think was the
coolest concept because again it
basically told us that for Ultron
there's no difference now in the comics
Ultron's far more ruthless he's far more
cruel of a being in this you know in the
movie Ultron felt like it was his duty
it felt like he was helping humanity by
destroying it in the comics he's just
like man screw humanity like those guys
suck I'm just gonna kill him because
whatever like I just hate them
definitely is in the comics I mean he's
pretty straightforward he's like
humanity sucks and I hate Hank Pym the
guy who made me and I'm just going to
kill everybody and that's that that's
basically the way Ultron is in the
comics and I like that element but I
think that while that element in the
comics is really just kind of a villain
of the week sort of thing in the sense
that he shows up fights The Avengers and
goes away and there's really not much
personality to him in the movie he had a
lot of personality and I think a lot of
that was brought to the main stage by
James Spader who was phenomenal as
Ultron but again I guess moving on when
we talked about the two things that the
worst saw and how one of them was
confirmed to be the the infinity gems
the other one I had mentioned was sort
of this theory again we saw that the
Scarlet Witch had used her powers to
manipulate or I guess the cast illusions
in the minds of people now what we don't
know is if these are illusions if these
are simply just things that people are
afraid of which seems to be the case or
if it's some kind of clairvoyance
because in a lot of instances in the
film it seems as those clairvoyance I
mean Tony Stark acts on his fear he
actually the fact that he knows this is
going to happen Thor sees the visions of
everything being destroyed and then
basically says this is because the
infinity gems are being gained I mean
the whole reason why he learns the
infinity gems are being collected is
because of the fact that he saw this
vision and so we don't really know which
one came first the chicken or the egg
but it seems to me that some measure of
clairvoyance is involved in this and so
when we saw Thor's we saw for seeing his
illusions with Heimdall and so on and so
forth
I don't know about you guys but that
looks like Ragnarok like I thought for a
split second we got a glimpse of Surtur
and that is huge because that basically
means that like everybody in NASCAR's
gonna die
and so I'm really curious to see what
what that means but that to me I think
right there was a glimpse of ragnarok it
was a glimpse of Thor seeing everybody
being killed of seeing Heimdall being
killed of seeing all the Asgardians
being wiped out and presumably surger
being the one behind it but again we
don't necessarily know that it's just
kind of a theory that I have going so I
wouldn't take that as an absolute fact
but I guess the next thing here the next
major thing and I think this is really
sort of a big deal is civil war one of
the coolest elements that I felt was
really sort of juxtaposed here and again
this could just be me seeing things not
really there was the giant crater that
we saw and in sokovia what it looked
like to me was this was sort of a homage
to the Civil War event when the wind
nitro blew up Stamford Connecticut but
rather than seeing somebody actually
blow up a neighborhood kill a hundred
people and 60 children or something like
that
this I think is basically going to kind
of boil to a head the events of Avengers
we saw a multitude of destruction we saw
we saw the Incredible Hulk when he was
controlled by the Scarlet Witch and
Avengers 2 just like lamb paging through
sokovia and causing all kinds of
violence and chaos the level of
destruction in this film was more so
than we had ever seen in the first
Avengers film it was unbelievable and it
was a destruction all over the place and
so I think this is basically going to be
the straw that broke the camel's back
this film the events that take place in
this movie combined with the events of
Captain America the Winter Soldier and
so on and so forth are going to be the
Stamford Connecticut of Civil War and
the comic books this is going to be the
event where the government finally says
enough is enough like we've had it with
superheroes blowing stuff up and then
just leaving it there because if you
noticed we saw start mentioned the I
guess the stark rescue or whatever it is
the crew that he has but that helps
clean things up but we don't know if he
involved that in sokovia we don't know
if that's a relatively new thing we
don't even know if that's something that
is really like a long-term thing does
that group go in and make sure people
are okay give them the kind of medical
treatment they need and then
or does it help to rebuild the entire
city if it doesn't help rebuild the
entire city then basically what's
happening if the superheroes are going
into a city they're fighting
supervillains and then they're leaving
the city to its own
I guess community to repair it which was
the basis behind Civil War like
governments and and various groups and
so on we're tired of seeing these
superheroes go into a city blow it all
out tear to pieces and then just say
well we'd be bad guys and then just walk
away and leave the city with the bill
basically to pay for everything and so
you know this I think is really going to
be like the the big leader I think it
was going to be the big event I wouldn't
be surprised and Captain America Civil
War if we see some reference to age of
Ultron of them saying that was a straw
that broke the camel's back that was the
last thing that's basically what did it
in the last thing I want to talk about
here before I bring this video to an
ends I want to talk about the vision I
want to talk about I want to talk about
his character I love the idea of the
vision um it's really difficult to make
this personality based comparison
between characters in the comics and
characters in the in movies because in
the comics they have whatever voice we
assigned to them you know their name is
pronounced however we choose to
pronounce it unless of course we're
talking about names based in existing
mythology for example the Asgardians
which are based in in mythology where I
guess Northmen Norse mythology that
exists already but you know characters
like the vision his personality the way
than the way in which he talks what his
voice sounds like these are all elements
that we throw in there and so when we're
reading these comments then we see the
vision talk the way which he
communicates is based on us and so to
see I guess Paul Bettany to basically
hear him talking like the vision to hear
the vision so calm to hear I'm so
collected to hear him so removed from
emotion in terms of excitement and anger
and rage and different things like that
and happiness I think is really really
interesting um it felt a lot more like
the vision that we saw in a vision quest
when vision had basically lost his soul
when he had lost the brain patterns of
Wonder Man and as a result he had no
real personality whatsoever but again
this is the very early stage of the
vision it could be that with this New
Avengers formation which includes the
vision that will see more personality as
the Marvel
matic universe progresses which I'm
hoping for because the vision was a
character that was basically constantly
trying to grow as a human being and so I
guess as a as an Android trying to
become human but the fact remains of
course as we know the vision wields
Thor's hammer which was a really cool
moment I was expecting it to happen like
once that scene started to unfold I said
okay either it's going to be in this
moment that he picks up Thor's hammer
either he's going to do it like absent
he in the same way we saw a banner pick
up the staff of Loki and Avengers or
he's going to do it consciously he's
simply going to pick up the hammer and
then people are going to be like wow and
it was hilarious sitting in the theater
because when he pick up the hammer
people were just like whoo my god which
was a huge moment it was it was really
fun it was a reaction I was hoping
people would have and I was really happy
to see that reaction but you know the
fact remains that that all in all while
it's not necessarily the most fluid of
the Avengers films while there is a lot
of jumping around what we really do just
jump from one scene to the next and it
really just kind of I guess a lot of
things just kind of seem to be thrown in
there um I thought it was a great movie
it was definitely interesting of course
I will buy it on blu-ray and just to
complete my Marvel Cinematic Universe
collection but um you know it was a
movie that I would definitely you know
that I definitely enjoyed so so yeah so
that's my review I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you guys have any questions feel
free to leave them down in the comment
section and and yeah so I will catch you
guys later peace